first thing of course that any new Prime
Minister will have to deal with its
brighter so what is your plan well it's
it's very straightforward we are in the
middle of a constitutional crisis and
nothing literally nothing can be done
until we get through brexit and the
choice we have to make as a Conservative
Party is who is the leader who is the
Prime Minister is most likely to get us
a deal that can get through Parliament
and allow us to do all the other really
important things that I want to do is
prime minister of this country and my
argument is as someone who has been a
negotiator all their life I set up and
ran my own business for 14 years I've
negotiated big deals in government
whether it's the junior doctors contract
dispute which is a very difficult one
the BBC license fee which was a an
incredibly short negotiation I have that
experience and if we can get a deal that
is the only way we will avoid a general
election and you've just been talking
about the the Peterborough by-election
with John Ashworth if we repeat going to
the country on a national scale then we
will see what happened at Peterborough
happening on a national scale which is
the right-wing vote center-right vote
split and labour coming through the
middle and that would be an absolute
catastrophe so what exactly would you do
differently then other than just
negotiating a bit better what would you
do different because the problems will
all be there still won't they when it
comes to press it well some of them will
and some of them will have changed but
we do have to learn from what went wrong
before and one of the reasons that
Brussels stopped negotiating with us
before was because they didn't think
that the British government could
deliver the British Parliament and so I
would put in my negotiating team a group
of people with the DUP the ERG who are
the brexit purists within the
Conservative Party's Scottish and Welsh
conservatives the only Robin to be out
limiting well it has to be led by
politicians because the people on the
other side of the table have to know
that the people they're talking to can
deliver that majority in parliament and
so anything we propose as a British
government has to have that credibility
that's the very first step so what's the
substance
that would have changed he said just
before that some things were so the same
and some things would change what what
would change well I had a conversation
with Angela Merkel earlier this week at
the D Day celebrations and I'm
absolutely clear that if we take the
right approach to this the Europeans
would be willing to negotiate on the
package she said exactly well she said
that you know of course with a new
British Prime Minister we would want to
look at any solutions you have she said
up to you said she said to me Germany
doesn't have that border with the
Republic of Ireland you do so you need
to come up with a solution it's
absolutely clear that solution well it's
clear that the backstop is not
acceptable to Parliament and so it's
going to be a solution that's based
around technologies what the Germans
call intelligent border and I think
that's doable but we have to find the
structures that reassure people that
this is deliverable and we have to find
the mechanisms to deal with the
situation where we can't agree on what
technology is capable of but if you're
asking me as someone who's who's done
deals all their life is there a deal
here yes there is and finding that deal
is going to mean approaching the EU with
the right kind of person if we go in
with an ultra hardline approach we will
get an ultra hardline response back and
then we'll get to the end of October and
nothing will have changed except we'll
be one step closer to a general election
so just very clearly come the 31st of
October
our current deadline if that deal hasn't
been done yet which if you were relying
on new technology is let's be frank
quite likely are you prepared to delay
or leave with No Deal well I've always
said that if the only way to leave the
European Union was without a deal then I
would do that because we have to honor
that referendum result but I would do so
with a heavy heart because of the
potential risks to business and indeed
to the Union and I wouldn't do it if
there was a prospect of a good deal and
you know a wise Prime Minister would say
instead of delayed oh if those were the
options well we don't know what choices
we're going to face then there's a very
high probability that Parliament will
take
No Deal off the table as it did in March
and so we don't know who the new
European Commission is going to be when
rule out another extension well what a
wise Prime Minister will do is take
decisions on the basis of the choices
that they have in front of them what an
unwise Prime Minister will do in this
situation is something that precipitates
a general election if you say the 31st
of October is a deadline come what may
and then Parliament blocks No Deal
the only way you can deliver that
promise is to have an election and
change Parliament and that would be
catastrophic for the Conservative Party
because just as in Peterborough as we
were saying Corbin would sneak through
the middle and the key thing here is
Jeremy Corbyn is never going to deliver
brexit I mean you look at the Labour
Party today and it's not going to happen
so if we want brexit we've got to be
very smart in the way we apreciate
approach this listening to what you're
saying you're effectively saying that
people need to trust you to do a better
negotiator effectively but I just
questioned some will wonder why they
should trust you on break say when you
have has a number of different positions
you voted remain you now say that you'd
vote leave if there was another
referendum back in 2016 you floated the
idea of a second referendum now you say
you don't want it in the amount of mark
for the referendum you also talked about
keeping the single market on the table
now you say you don't want to be in the
single market you've previously said
that we'd survive and prosper without a
deal now you say it would be political
suicide I mean how do we know what you
actually think on it my position has
been completely consistent I didn't say
no deal would be political suicide what
I said is going into an election would
be political suicide I've always said
that we should implement the referendum
result and I've always said that there
should be Democratic endorsement of the
type of brexit that we do and that's
indeed what happened because we had a
general election where more than 80
percent of the country voted for parties
that wanted to leave the single market
and at that stage the customs union
because that was Labour's policy at that
time the question now is not how you
voted in a referendum three years ago it
is who has the skills to live to deliver
a deal that is going to get us out of
the EU before we have a general election
and I have those skills and I am
passionate about changing this can
for the better and all sorts of things
but the one thing I would say as an
entrepreneur I'm gonna fire up the
economy I want to help thousands of
young people do the things that I did
when I was setting out from University
and I'm excited to do that but those
skills are also relevant to the
situation we're in now you need to have
a negotiator this is about the art of
tough negotiation not the art of empty
rhetoric and you're launching your
strategy on that note to try and win
over young voters something the
Conservative Party hasn't exactly been
doing very well out recently what what
do you want to do
well I'm 52 and basically anyone younger
than me is more likely to vote labor
than conservative and just three years
ago that tipping age was 35 so if that
continues as a party we are just going
to die on our feet and I'm not one of
those people who says that we should
always accept the young people are going
to vote left and then when they get a
mortgage and have a family they'll move
to the right we as the party of
aspiration have to have a message for
young aspirational people now I joined
the Conservative Party when I was 19
years old and my dreams were to set up
my own business to save up for a family
to buy a house and those dreams were
also Prime Minister's kind of the back
of them somewhere but I wanted to do
those other things first and you know
the truth is that that was also at that
time it's the late 1980s that was
Conservative government policy to make
those dreams happen if Jeremy Corbyn
gets in it will be Labour government
policy to stop those dreams so it was
the party of aspiration we've got a very
strong message I mean Jeremy calm
clearly stated that's not what Jeremy
Corbyn government would do but but look
at the record of even less left-wing
labour leaders than Jeremy Corbyn every
single one has left unemployment higher
when they left office than when they
arrived in office as compared to a
Conservative government's created a
thousand jobs for every single day we've
been in office so that's the
opportunities for young people and we if
we can get that across was a 19 year old
Jeremy hunt like were you well behaved
do you get into trouble look I think
every 19 year old does things that they
wouldn't want their mom and dad to find
out
I think my mum could well be listening
right now but but you know isn't in
drugs well I said I I drank a cannabis
lassi when I was backpacking through
India as the really Countess doing drugs
I don't know but look I had a fantastic
time when I was young I lived life to
the full but I also had big dreams and
if we're going to succeed as a country
we've got to be the kind of place that
allows young people to fulfill their
dreams to reach for the stars I had a
dream of setting up a business I didn't
have any capital from my family and I I
got going got it off the ground with my
best friend and I was very proud to do
that other people will have different
dreams but the fundamental difference
between us and the Labour Party is that
we know that if we bag
young people to make their dreams come
true we all benefit from that and that's
what I want to talk about today now
previously and on an issue that I know
many people feel very strongly about
abortion you have said that you would
like to see the legal time lit from
abortion being reduced from 24 weeks to
12 weeks is that story of you well these
are matters of conscience yes my view
hasn't changed on that and I respect the
fact that other people have very
different views and that's why these
matters are always matters for free
votes in the House of Commons and and
when they come up people vote with their
conscience can you guarantee that if
your Prime Minister the time limit for
abortion stay where it is
what I can guarantee is that this will
be a matter for the House of Commons not
a matter for government policy the Prime
Minister will have his view just like
every other one of the 650 MPs and these
will be decided as a matter of
conscience but it won't be a government
policy to change the law in that respect
it's not about that you would bring its
it won't be government policy to have a
vote I you know if backbenchers choose
to have a vote then we'd have a free
vote and everyone would vote with their
conscience
okay now this week you met Donald Trump
six times quite a lot did you take him
aside and explain to him that you don't
think the NHS should be part of a trade
deal did that come up in your
conversations yes I did have that
conversation with him I don't think he's
the world's biggest expert on the NHS
but what he is a big expert on his trade
deals and he's very very keen to do a
trade deal with the UK and he reiterated
that and I just explained to him that
you know the NHS couldn't be part of a
trade deal and I think he understands
that so it was you who made him change
his mind was that what you're trying to
say I think anyone who claims that they
got Donald Trump - changed their mind
might be over egging is a bit but I
certainly made that point to him as I
think any of the other candidates in
this contest would have if they had
spoken to him is he a good president he
is a strong president there are things
that I fundamentally disagree with him
about climate change would be one the
Iran nuclear deal will be did you raise
this absolutely but there are other
things where I think we can learn from
his he has got American growth at about
double the levels in the UK if we had
GDP growth of 3% for a sustained period
of time we'd have an extra 20 billion
pounds to spend on public services when
I was running the NHS I really knew how
much we need to put resources into our
vital public services so there's a there
are things that we can learn from his
approach and he's also an effective
communicator you may not agree with
everything that he says when he tweets
but he takes a lot of trouble to talk to
the American people and I think in
modern politics we have to learn from
that as well talking about learning from
other people's approach you've picked up
the reins at the Foreign Office from
Boris Johnson what how did he leave it
do you think he was a good foreign
secretary well Boris has had a very big
impact on Britain's position in the
world because he led the brexit campaign
and well we are going to make it a
terrific success because you know when
we've implemented the referendum result
we can do amazing things as a country
but he was quite a Marmite character of
course and there were people other
European foreign ministers who found him
difficult to deal with because of his
views on brexit but you knew as if they
said to you about that well these are
private conversations and but what I do
when talking to those other European
governments what I hear the whole time
is they want to do a deal with us if we
approach this the right way they will
talk to us but
this is a problem for them as well as us
and I don't think we should be
despondent about the fact that this is a
very challenging situation because you
know a great country like Britain we
have been through far far worse in our
history and we can get through this we
can make a terrific success of this and
I think we will okay and finally I hope
Sky News is going to be as you know
hosting a debate a head-to-head debate
with the final two candidates if you
make it through to the final two can you
commit to taking part in that live
debate with Sky News I would be
delighted to do so I've had the email
from you your head of news already and
and told him that as well do you think
you'll get through I think I've got a
very good chance because the fundamental
choice we've got is what type of person
is going to be able to go to Brussels
and get a deal and when you think about
that in that way and you think about the
risks to our country if we don't get a
deal and we end up with a general
election then there's only one answer
why you say why about general election
if your Prime Minister when you win
because I do want be very happy to fight
a general election but I want to fight a
general election having delivered what
we promised to do last time which is
backs it and I think if we go before
then people will rightly say why are you
asking for another mandate when you
haven't you guys haven't done what you
said you did last time I think we can
deliver it that's what I want to do
foreign secretary thank you very much
for being on the program thank you